i want to show you another quick sneak
peek this is something that i posted on
twitter a couple days ago quick sneak
peek from the film and this relates to
you know everything we talked about
really in the opening
um
the it's sort of the logical conclusion
of the leftist
sexual
agenda what what happens when we become
unmoored from truth onward from reality
from our moral tradition
and we uh took the rabbit hole all the
way down in the film so i want to play
this clip from what is a woman which is
available now at what is woman.com you
can become a subscriber and watch but
here it is watch
so now we are seeing kids that are
identifying as animals going to school
and they are purring instead of
answering questions and they meow and
the teachers are not allowed to question
it because it's considered a queer
identity so
if kids are going to school and they're
saying i'm a cat
and the teachers have to
affirm them as a cat
yes so it's not
the literal literal zoos now basically
they
are i am a 27 year old transgender woman
um i am a wolf therian and a member of
the furry fandom when and how did you
discover this inner wolfeness um
probably around age 10 or 11. i was
watching an anime about wolves and
see the wolf running across the screen
and i'm somehow just intrinsically like
oh that's me have you spent any time
around biological wolves yes
that sounds dangerous also what context
are you so i was a volunteer with the
preserve and i've also visited many wolf
preserves are you able to communicate
with the wolves am i going to have a
conversation with a wolf in the way that
i'm communicating you and i obviously
not am i going to read their body
language respond appropriately to their
behaviors and their nonverbal cues yes
would you be would you be able to give
us an example of
this wolf communication um no i'm not
comfortable doing so okay all right
i mean i thought i'd ask anyone
uh i would be interested to know i mean
i i still would would like to know what
um
really what the interpersonal
communication between a wolf is like and
you see that and you think well that's
uh absurd and you can kind of laugh
about it and sure but
you know i'm telling you right now this
is not uh
this is not any kind of um
[Music]
extreme slippery slope
possibility i think that
a few years from now that someone i
don't know if it's going to be me but
someone's going to have to make a film
called what is a human because
this trans species stuff this is not
um just a fringe
fad
you know outlier type of thing
this as we heard from sarah stockton
who's the therapist in the first part of
that clip
this is a very common thing
and she's not the only one saying that
you know we hear from people that work
in the schools therapists that feel like
they can speak out without being having
their careers destroyed that this is
this is the thing now
kids this is what kids are doing
and it's like well and of course kids
are doing that
when you tell kids that hey you could be
whatever you want to be
your identity is up to you of course a
lot of them are going to say
oh well then i'm a i'm a wolfer i'm a
whatever i'm a monkey
and and usually in like an insane
society kids
pretending to be animals as long as
they're kids now the person we were
talking to there the was a wolf therian
not a kid that's an adult but for kids
pretending to be animals usually it's uh
my own kids do that sometimes
my two-year-old runs around pretending
to be named and that's that's perfectly
fine that's you using your imagination
except that we don't live in a sane
society and so now uh we latch on to
that and say okay well that that's your
right that's who you are now that's your
identity
that's not that's not just a game that's
who you are
so look out for the sequel what is a
human dropping sometime in the next few
years
well i hope you enjoyed that clip for
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content